l'avis de lovely bord gagnent ne s'est
pas arrêtée le 12 janvier 2010 le jour
de son amputation
elle venait d'avoir 15 ans shao jugé blé
à vrai dire c'est la vie à la suite du
séisme près de cinq mille haïtiens ont
perdu une part de maine
aujourd'hui on les aperçoit un peu
partout des laissés-pour-compte souvent
forcés à la mendicité anti jo le 12
janvier j'ai perdu ma jambe raide
l'église sacré coeur
je passais par là et le séisme est
arrivé j'ai passé trois jours par terre
parce que tout était coincé il y avait
des poteaux électriques à terre sur la
route des murailles tomber la route
était complètement bloquée c'était
vraiment catastrophique
depuis il caressait le maire s'est
installé dans un campement de fortune
devant les vestiges de la grande
cathédrale de port au prince
il vit dans une tente rafistolé avec sa
femme et ses trois enfants
mais il est débrouillard il a réussi à
se procurer une télévision qu'il fait
fonctionner en volant d'électricité je
remercie dieu de m'avoir laissé la vie
j'ai perdu une jambe mais je remercie le
ciel de m'avoir laissé en vie car il ya
des gens qui ont perdu beaucoup plus que
moi
il ya des familles qui sont natale
la vie des personnes handicapées reste
encore bien difficile ici même si des
organisations internationales leur
fournissent parfois des prothèses lovely
a cessé de porter la sienne depuis
longtemps non qu'est ce que vous auriez
voulu une quête qui est très confortable
moi je les congolais considère
généralement moi personnellement je les
considère comme faisant partie des des
pauvres des pauvres
michel péan sait de quoi il parle lui
même est aveugle
en 2010 il était au gouvernement
responsable de l'intégration des
personnes handicapées
un combat qu'il poursuit depuis 20 ans
vous savez que dans la mentalité
traditionnelle haïtienne
les personnes handicapées sont comme des
invalides ziadi des personnes n'ayant ni
droit ni de voir des invalides à dire
des gens qu'on n'a pas besoin d'envoyer
à l'école des gens qui n'ont pas droit
d'attaquer d'avoir accès au marché du
travail
lovely a de la chance sa mère croit en
elle et elle peut encore poursuivre ses
études
mais pour combien de temps comme tant
d'autres la famille a tout perdu et vit
maintenant dans ce camp c'est le camp
des handicapés peu après le tremblement
de terre ils ont été regroupées l'a
coincé entre deux des quartiers les plus
dangereux de port au prince
des amputés des aveugles des
sourds-muets 1600 personnes oubliées par
la communauté internationale et par les
autorités le v'lille partagent cet abri
avec huit autres personnes en plus
difficile c'est un la façon où j'ai vu
parce qu'on est pas avant j'étais part
comme ça
avant c'était mieux parce que je vivais
dans les maisons des confortables
je n'avais pas tellement de comme les
problèmes pour aller à l'école pour moi
j ai pour dormir
non mais maintenant oui au lendemain du
12 janvier c'est extrêmement difficile
pour les personnes âgées
de même que les personnes en situation
de handicap d'avoir accès bas exemple
aux produits alimentaires ont distribué
dans le pays parce que ça se faisait
dans dans un désordre inouïe
vous comprenez les policiers
intervenaient gouverneur de matraques et
cetera et cetera ne pouvait pas demander
à une personne handicapée d'aller de ces
espaces
devant l'urgence le gouvernement à
promulguer une nouvelle loi pour mieux
protéger les handicapés et leur
permettre de travailler 2 % du personnel
de toutes les entreprises doivent en
principe être des personnes handicapées
will mark jean amputé d'une jambe a pu
justement profiter d'un salon de
l'emploi spéciale organisée par le
gouvernement
il y avait beaucoup d'entreprises qui
voulait recruter des personnes
handicapées sur la base assure la base
de charité mais sur la base de leurs
compétences
il a été embauchée au service à la
clientèle d'une station de télévision
je peux dire c'est une sorte de
réintégration pour moi le fait que vous
prête des activités rp 3 1 10 mois
mais ils sont encore nombreux à se
sentir exclu c'est maintenant que
j'entends dire qu'il ya des efforts qui
se font mais ces changements n'arrive
pas encore à moins que comme il ya la
vie de lovely ne s'est pas améliorée est
ce que le gouvernement a fait assez pour
vous 1 et n'ont rien du tout mais
l'oubli refuse de se laisser abattre
elle espère trouver les moyens pour
terminer ses études il nourrit même de
grands rêves
qu'est ce que tu aimes armure la ville
d'omaha est ce que tu penses qu'avec ta
jambe comme ça tu vas pouvoir un jour
réaliser ton rêve notre mission oui